la mamá de romario veloz y su pareja
claman por justicia el padre de la
pequeña maite de 6 años es uno de los 31
fallecidos que según cifras oficiales
dejó el estallido social en chile casi
un año después y tras protestar frente a
la moneda reciben la noticia de que un
capitán del ejército será procesado por
su muerte me da pena que haya tenido que
pasar todo esto de que él fue a luchar
por un futuro por el futuro de su hija
porque esa fue la explicación que me dio
a mí frank esto está mal y la maté
chilena
y el final y terminó todo con el muerto
el caso de romario ilustra muchos otros
según la fiscalía chilena durante el
estallido se registraron casi cuatro mil
700 querellas contra agentes del estado
el instituto de derechos humanos
presentó más de 2500 y en sólo 31 casos
se encontraron posibles culpables es
decir apenas el 1 por ciento pasar del
tiempo también da un temor a las
víctimas de la impunidad que ya ha
vivido en nuestro país entonces se
vuelve a repetir una historia que
queremos persistentemente impedir que se
vuelva a repetir la fiscalía cifra en
más de 3.000 las lesiones de arma de
fuego y en 413 las víctimas de lesiones
oculares junto a torturas violaciones
abusos sexuales y otros delitos en 5
meses de protestas amnistía
internacional pide que no haya impunidad
un informe reciente concluye que los
altos mandos de la policía chilena
conocían las cifras a diario y no
hicieron nada para detenerlas
en responsabilidad penal acusan también
al gobierno pero trauma de nuestros
hijos también creemos que si el
ejecutivo del presidente sebastián
piñera hubiera ejercido un adecuado
control sobre esta institución estas
violaciones no se hubieran dado de una
forma tan masiva
a un año del estallido los muros en
chiles siguen hablando y los chilenos
pidiendo justicia
ah
y
[Música]